Sona how are you I'm all right I'm not
I'm not bad okay
great great it's so it's awkward when
you answer that because also we've been
sitting for a lot how I'm doing how are
you doing I'm doing great thanks not
awkward at all Gorly how are you oh dude
[Laughter]
well I don't understand uh I um maybe
it's because for 28 years uh I would say
good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the show I'd say things that
were kind of phony like that so maybe
I'm used to it I'm not you know we'll
take a quick break we'll be right back
with more fun I used to do that I used
to say things like that every night yeah
no one says things like that it's a very
weird job yeah hey we're back all right
yeah I mean why well because you were
throwing to Commercial and you were
coming back from oh thanks for reminding
me she had to say those things okay but
there's also yeah like we've been in
this room together for a while talking
so when you're like how are you doing
it's like well we covered that like yeah
we have chatter when we first come in
the room when we talk to each other as
human beings and then we start the show
yeah so you come in and berate us you
don't even say hi and then then we do
this yeah yeah also God forbid we laugh
before when it's not recorded then you
and Adam both are just like you know
because start recording because a wasted
laugh is I think the greatest crime in
the universe yeah it tops the murder of
an Angel what about you know it really
does like when it when a laugh when
there's a good hearty laugh and it's not
recorded it's like if a tree falls in
the forest and no one sees it did it
fall I think if a laugh happens off Mike
it's nothing it's not even a laugh but
what about a shared chuckle among
friends that's even a rich no what about
when you're at like dinner with your
friends and you guys are chuckling I
might I make everything oh yeah oh you
might yeah no if I go to the funny part
yeah
hey guys let me get the equipment you
have a duffel bag you'd like to see me
get my equipment and I'll tell you that
much right now no I if I if I'm gonna
have whenever I'm having dinner with
like a Marty Short or a bill hater or
any of these really funny people or John
Mulaney I say to Eduardo I'm going to
dinner with some funny people bring your
stuff and Eduardo makes it you get to go
it's been fun come on he doesn't get to
eat
where is he sitting he's under the table
working the equipment
yeah and you don't even throw them some
scraps or anything I tried that once but
it turns out he has a nut allergy
yeah I didn't know I just shoved some
peanuts down there and then I heard
someone's lungs give out wait why isn't
he under the table while we record here
adorable get under the table there are
certain there are certain uh Union rules
that we must follow but when I'm out to
dinner I can get away with Moira
so uh you know I do feel that way I do
feel that before if there's a lot of
laughing and joking around and the
laughs are just bouncing around the room
and they're not being recorded it's like
sacred Blood Of The Gods seeping into
the soil no I want that saved now is
that for the posterity of humankind or
is it because you want to know that
there are more people out there feeding
off you off you like second one yeah
giving you somehow an energy out there
in the world laughing the minute you
said is it for posterity and the
goodness of I knew it was going to be
the second one I was just like whatever
the second one is it's that one hey
whether you're stuck in traffic or
streaming your favorite podcasts that's
where I come in it's important to have a
network you can trust wherever you are
say it with me T-Mobile yeah you didn't
really have to say it with me but it is
your network you know I'm excited about
T-Mobile yeah you're killing it and uh
you know I was really excited is our
good friend blay yes who's been using
this service blade tell us about it yeah
I have been a T-Mobile a subscriber for
a really long time it they're awesome I
download videos all the time yeah you do
you like you download a lot of videos
yeah now you've never read a book no no
books are overrated but uh and I listen
to this podcast on a hike fantastic up
in the mountains you'd listen to our
podcast I will contract you work here
yeah I have to I have to I have to
listen to it but it's great and and
honestly like the coverage is is insane
uh and yeah I love the service I love
the phone it's fantastic experience for
yourself how T-Mobile is America's
largest and fastest 5G Network you can't
top them I like all the G's you bet you
do find out more at t-mobile.com Cy
that's
s-e-e-w-h-y fastest based on median
overall combined 5G speeds according to
analysis by UCLA of speed test
intelligence data four
Q4 2022 good wow that's incredible yeah
I said exactly what they wanted me
5G details at
t-mobile.com you want people to think
you're funny yes oh Bingo oh my God and
I want to capture those laughs oh I want
to capture those laughs that's why I
think it's good to turn the mics on
right away and Sony you come in some
days and you just start babbling right
away and then and then you're laughing
and you've only got so many you've only
got so many laughs in you in a day and
we've got to capture them all on the mic
she's the greatest laugher he's a great
laugher but she's only got so many no I
don't I can laugh forever not true no
it's been this is medically proven oh
yeah yeah how old are you now 40. yeah
40 year old woman has like maybe nine
laughs in her a day nine true story yeah
man have like six so I just like even if
something's funny to me I just don't
laugh uh laughs require a lot of calcium
and we lose cows assume over time I've
studied this extensively yeah yeah
right now you just lost last three
vertebrae
precious last three vertebrae yeah
oh no your left hip just shattered come
on no don't do that it's true story okay
if you say it's true then it's truth
yeah all you have to do is say true
story if I was a lawyer that's what I do
when someone my client said something
I'd just be at my true story Case Closed
true story uh I object your honor yeah
the opposing Council keeps yelling true
story every time his client says him
I wish I was a lawyer do you yeah I
don't oh I would because I would do all
that stuff I think I'd be very funny in
the courtroom I think I'd be very very
funny not effective as a lawyer oh
terrible lawyer oh my my clients would
go to the electric chair left and right
and they wouldn't be up for capital
crimes you know they'd be like
jaywalking electric chair but I would
have so much fun saying I object your
honor and then jumping into the witness
box and then jumping out doing all that
stuff I would love doing that yeah what
do you think you would have done if you
weren't doing comedy I think I've been
murdered a long time ago okay yeah that
makes sense I don't know what I would
have been doing I I don't know what
would you be doing I don't know what
I've been doing
even contemplating it made my mouth fall
apart oh yeah I do not know it's a very
good question I think he'd be an
insufferable history teacher yes yes
yeah yeah
yeah
the whole time
come in with his glasses upside down
going did you hear what happened to the
Battle of Hastings you know yeah let's
not get Hastings now no I think I would
take your class of course you would all
the all the ladies would want to take my
class oh that I'll be like who's that
dreamy Professor okay all right I guess
love you on your eyelids like Indiana
Jones God you are so obsessed with
Harrison Ford and Indiana Jones so
anybody listening would not know that
because we talked about it off mic yeah
okay see and why didn't you uh put that
on Mike you know well you anytime you
work Harrison Ford into more
conversations
he's great yeah yeah